hey no hurt me afraid I'm not as at  Rachel year there's a tranche Allah here  natural oh just dictate but I am afraid  my dear Santa bleah so so I came to the  apartment for the first time and I was  like watch this is my fun would read  what is on the end of that there's  nothing there's nothing de Baca stop  bead and so cupcake these but the  trenches name is cupcake of course it is  now it's piss it's like [ __ ] you i know  you're [ __ ] know this ain't no it's  good it's like Suri Cruise it knows it's  getting filmed right now and it hates it  oh my god Oh touching it Oh cupcake  please oh my god what does it do in  there  oh how she knows its face it's a girl to  go oh ok I'm a little sad for you  cupcake cupcake hates it cupcake hockey  gloves ug lifestyle speaking bougie  lifestyle look at this carpet wall you  crazy